Well Kirk, I appreciate you taking
the time to be with us today.
>> Definitely.
>> You're the Chief Technology Officer
at Wellcentive,
a local company here in Atlanta.
And the company has
an interesting founding story.
Could you briefly tell us about that?
>> Yeah, absolutely.
Two brother-in-laws were really
talking over Christmas drinks.
One of the brother-in-laws was Dr.
Paul Taylor, and
he was producing reports in Excel for
payers, trying to summarize his
own quality using claims data.
And it was just way too cumbersome,
very difficult, and inaccurate,
and the other brother in law was
working at Patient Care Technologies.
Was a software designer and
they realized,
hey this is a trend that
really needs to happen.
Physicians need to be paid
on quality long term.
And there's absolutely a market here.
They stayed small for four or five
years, invested a lot in the product.
Delivered real results to significant
customers in the Michigan area.
I joined about three years ago, and
I had a unique history that followed
along with their path, as well.
I worked at MedQuist and M*Modal.
There I saw 20 terabytes of rich
text files of pure narrative, and
we said,
we have to tap into that information.
But natural language processing and the
different context that you might look at
that narrative text in, offered many,
many challenges that I felt would
take a long time to really to get to
the value that I wanted to get to.
So, I then looked at a company called
Outcomes Health Informations Solutions,
and what they did,
was they literally put nurses on site,
picked up a paper medical record,
scanned it, uploaded it to another bank
of nurses that would read the paper,
and then essentially abstract
the information to answer a specific
question that a payer would have.
And payers would pay $80 a chart for
that process to happen.
It was a mess.
An absolute nightmare of
a workflow that led to
lower data quality and higher cost.
The whole time I was there, I said,
can't we get this data out of the EHR?
And lo and behold, three years ago,
I found this company, Wellcentive,
that was working on exactly that.
>> Well that's a great story.
In lesson ten we'll talk a bit more
about feature selection out of natural
language records.
And I guess these nurses were the first
generation of technology for doing that.
>> Yep.
Absolutely.
>> So let's segue forward to today.
Today you're gathering data from
lots of doctor's practices and EMRs.
Can you give us those numbers?
>> Yeah, we have about 1,000 practices,
8,000 physicians.
We have over 2,500 interfaces pumping
data into our data center every day.
We process about 200 million
clinical data points every month.
And one of my favorite stats is that
we have sent 178 million transactions
to payers that have resulted in
a value based reimbursement payment.
And it's all based on clinical quality.
Okay, that sounds like a lot of
stuff from a lot of sources.
How do you do it?
>> That's easier asked than answered,
but
it really comes down to being aggressive
with respect to seeking out the data.
So that means that for our customers,
what we need to do is we need to go to
them and say, you know what, I don't
care what format of the data you have.
Your system exports data somehow,
some way, it's just a file format.
People have been parsing files for
a long, long time.
So we just roll up our sleeves,
we have a flexible platform that allows
us to administer many different types of
format parsing,
many different types of protocols.
And it creates a queue of processing and
enterprise servers bus of processing
that allows us to process and interpret
that data as we hit our application, and
put that data into a structured
form in an application side.
>> And I want to emphasize that you're
not just collecting quality metrics,
which the students should know are
relatively standardized at this point.
But you're collecting
clinical data from EMRs.
And of course, by now,
the students have already seen that.
They've seen some of the things you do.
How do you normalize and
standardize that clinical data when
it comes from 200 different EMRs?
>> The key to that is being
what we say purpose driven.
We don't try to boil the ocean and
standardize every data point
that we find in each document.
We work with the provider organization
to say what are your clinical
quality goals?
And how are you going to
be paid based on this data?
And we specifically look at all the file
formats that they give us, and we pick
out the pieces of data that relate
to those clinical quality measures.
And so that, first,
simplifies the problem and
allows us to really focus on data
quality within that specific domain.
Then we essentially maintain
a dictionary of all code sets.
And we have over 2.2 million
mappings that we have curated
over the past eight years that relate
the customers custom dictionaries
to all the national standard
dictionaries that exist out there.
>> Well,
what about the patient in all of this?
This is clinical data from the EMR.
How do you manage the obvious
privacy and security concerns?
>> Well, it's very important.
And I actually respect,
a lot, the high tech act.
When we went into our first HIPAA risk
assessment, you get pretty nervous.
But as you go through it you realize
that it's a very healthy process.
They have a long checklist of
about 170 something regulations.
That as we went through it, we just
made sure that we hit on each of those
and that we're diligent and respectful
internally to our organization.
Our people deal with
clinical data all day long.
They're helping our customers
measure clinical quality.
And so quite a bit of education within
the company about how to handle that
data responsibly is required.
>> So, a patient like the make believe
chronic, multi chronic disease patient,
Marla, that we've created for
this course.
Whose going to lots of
different specialists,
becomes a real challenge to
know where is her record?
Whose caring for her?
And how do you define quality
in a patient like that?
>> Yeah.
That's very, very tricky.
So one of the biggest
problems that Marla can pose,
is not going to the doctor at all.
And how do you know if you're
missing clinical data,
maybe you just don't
have that interface?
Maybe you don't have that relationship
with that doctor that she went to see?
So, I think what's happening right now
is provider organizations are a single
legal structure or
entity, they're starting to
solve this problem internally.
And it goes to some other topics
like the roll out of direct and
the roll of HIEs, is if you're solving
this problem internally to that
provider organization, that legal
structure, how do the community
structures that are outside of
that organization participate?
Well, you mentioned Direct,
which is one of the technologies that I
mentioned frequently here on the course.
What do you see as the role of Direct
in this complex mix of doctors,
patients and
quality metrics that you've laid out?
>> Wellcentive is unique in that
we're both in analytics and
population health management,
clinical quality, system but
we're also meaningful you certified.
We do that for a couple of reasons.
One, because there's always a point
of aspect to clinical quality.
But, two, we have to play nicely
with all of the standards
that are out there with all
the core point of care EHR.
So that means, supporting direct and
supporting standards like CCDA.
The problem with the industry right now
is that Direct is a very
flexible technology once set up.
There's quite a bit of setup,
quite a bit of administration
to getting it set up.
And what we're seeing is that internally
to that provider organization that we
were talking about, it's much easier
just to bring the data in directly from
the EMRs and not worry so much about
the protocols and the directed
aspect of Direct, which means a provider
can direct a chart to another provider.
We see Direct as really
being more the protocol for
bringing data from external
to that provider organization
from the HIE, and
those structures are really just getting
adopted by the communities and
by the provider organizations today.
>> Well, one final question and
then I'll let you go.
Put on your crystal ball glasses,
and tell us where you think we're going
in the area of population health,
quality measurement, and
even outcome based incentives.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
This is a fascinating space.
I'm very honored to be part of solving
these problems in the industry.
The most fundamental problem in the
industry today is again saying how do we
pay based on quality versus
paying based on a fee for
service action, a single action?
And because the patients a consumer and
they can go to many different places,
you end up having data
that contributes to the quality
spread across multiple systems.
So you then have to bring that
data together to really assess
the total quality.
In this comes a lot of deep
questions about who is responsible
for each of the quality actions,
but also,
which record do I look at across these
different EHRs or in the population
of health management system to determine
that quality action was taken.
The FTC has created clinical
integration network
guidelines that essentially say
that a provider organization cannot
contract with payers unless
they are clinically integrated.
And what that means is that they,
the organization has to behave as one
unit from a clinical
quality perspective.
They have to be following the same
standards, processes and procedures.
That's easier said than done.
And so workflows and health systems need
to modify their internal structures and
their internal investments over time to
be able to even allow this work flow and
the physician work flow to understand
the entire spectrum of a longitudinal
patient record.
So what's happening there
is that's getting refined.
Once we achieve physician
engagement in that process, and
we have high data quality.
I then expect patient engagement and
the empowerment of the consumer
in healthcare to really flourish.
I think it's going to
stagnate until then.
But after that I really see
patient engagement taking off and
putting the power of the care but also
the incentives into the patient's hand.
>> Yeah I couldn't agree more.
I think the whole role of the patient
in patient engagement just keeps
becoming more and
more prominent as time goes on.
>> Yes.
>> Well I want to thank you again.
>> Absolutely.
>> You've not only
given us an interesting technology story
which weaves in many of the themes of
the course.
But a great entrepreneurial story.
Two guys having a drink and
now we have a major company in
the population health space.
So thank you very much.
>> Absolutely.
Thank you very much.